The Joe Rogan experience, this message.
Is this something that you have sort of developed over the years of arguing with
people about.
No, it's mostly from, uh, what we did at whole foods.
Cause I had no background in business. Right? I'm an entrepreneur. I didn't,
I started here right in Austin. That's right. First store here, 40,
over 42 years ago.
Jesus. You look great. How old are you? 67 look. Very good. Well.
Thank you you right now. Look when rolling.
Up. You're eating all that whole foods, eating all that healthy whole foods.
That is one thing that you guys did do. That's very interesting. Right?
You created a market where like, if you tell people I go to whole foods,
you know, people are like, Oh, well you care about your health. Like you're,
it's synonymous with healthy foods. Even in the name,
whole foods.
That was our brand when we were up in calmer. And then when we got really rich,
uh, America loves the up and calmer,
but then once you have become really successful, you're making a lot of money.
They start to turn on you. Oh no. Well we became whole paycheck. Who said that?
I don't know, but whoever did I wish.
I never saw it. You never saw that until right now.
You just on yourself in a way that I never, all I heard was whole foods.
I never heard whole paycheck. Then you, your.
Team didn't do good research. Have.
No team. So does this, when you sold the Amazon?
No, no.
The whole paycheck thing has been around for a long time because the whole
paycheck, meaning. Cause it's so expensive. Yes.
Because initially when we were up in calmer, you, if you shot that whole food,
you were showing everybody, you were sort of,
you were with it and you were hip and cool.
And then the narrative went sour because it's like, um, it's,
you're a fool for shopping there because you can get the same food cheaper
elsewhere. So you're going to whole paycheck.
So the narrative turned a negative so to speak. Um,
I still see that pretty much all the time.
Although since our merger with Amazon, we've cut our prices many, many times.
How'd you do that? Amazon allowed whole foods to think long-term again,
we needed to cut our prices. But when you're a public company,
if you're selling something for a dollar and you say, you know what,
we need to sell this for 90 cents and you start selling it for 90 cents in the
short run,
you just cut your sales 10% because you're just not selling any more of it over
the long-term people will realize, man, I can get a good deal for 90 cents.
They used to pay a buck for it and they start to shop with you more. And,
and your S your sales will go up.
But when you're a public company and the market's very short-term oriented,
you pay a heavy price in the short term for reducing your prices.
And Amazon is willing to think longterm and let whole foods do that.
Just Jeff Bezos got that long money son.
He has a long money because he's had,
he's had a lot of brilliant ideas and put together a pretty, pretty good team.
Yeah. What keeps that guy working when you, when you have 150 in the bank,
150 billion, what keeps you going?
And it doesn't have it in the bank. He's got it in stock. Few in the,
he's got a few in the bank. Probably. I feel like he could probably relax.
I mean, I think I, the same thing that keeps me going at age 67, I mean,
uh, building something's great fun and building whole foods. I don't, I mean,
I've got plenty of money, Joe. I don't need to work. I just like it.
You still run whole foods. Like, what's your relationship there? I'm still CEO.
So you still work long hours.
I don't work as long today as I did when I was in my twenties and thirties.
There's no question about it. Cause I was putting a lot of 80 hour,
weeks and year after year after year after year now you're building something,
you know, it wasn't work. It was play. I was having a blast. It was fun.
Elon Musk is famously said that if you're in a tech startup and you're not
working 120 hour weeks, you won't succeed. Yeah.
I never been at a tech startup. So I can't speak for that.
The grocery business wasn't quite that hard, but we did put a lot of 80 hours.
Seems.
Like not a lot of time to sleep.
And I'm a great believer in sleep. Sleep is high. Like how many.
Hours are left? How many hours are in a week? Well,
let's say there's 24 hours, 168 hours a week,
160. You only have 48 hours to sleep. That is ridiculous. You won.
So that's well, I don't know if you,
all you did was that 48 hours divided by seven that's almost seven hours a
night. If all you did was work and sleep. I don't know when he eats.
Maybe you have to eat when you're working, you have to eat. When eating,
you got to go to the bathroom. Sometime you got to scratch that out.
So you sleep seven hours a night and just stay at work. Yeah.
I don't actually think you have to put a lot of energy into build anything,
but um, if you're doing it right,
we talk a lot about conscious capitalism is about higher purpose.
If you have a purpose, that's animating you. It doesn't feel like work.
It feels like play. It also attracts people to you that share that same purpose.
This is something that I find very frustrating and people that don't recognize
that it is incredibly difficult to build a successful business when they just
want to tax the out of people and take all that money. Like,
do you think it's easy to make something like whole foods?
Do you think it's easy to make a company like Tesla? Do you think it's easy?
It's not easy. It's an insanely difficult task.
That's why most people don't do it.
But when someone does do it and they have become successful,
then other people start looking at it and go, well, they have all this money.
They should contribute more or they should do this. Or, you know,
you're talking about, uh,
some people have suggested some extraordinary tax rates in order to get us out
of this current recession. And, uh, uh,
then I talked to business people and they say that is the exact wrong approach
because that's actually gonna stifle business and businesses.
The only thing that's going to bring us out of this,
if you incentivize businesses to take risks and to be open and to
make more profits than more people are going to get jobs,
then the economy bounces back.
But if you give them a gigantic tax burden,
they're going to be less likely to take chances.
They're not going to be able to survive that. And people on the outside,
who've never built a business like whole foods. They don't to see that.
They don't see it. Um, the reality is,
is that people like an Elon Musk or Jeff Bezos,
um, they are they're good capital allocators, so to speak.
They're not going to waste that money.
That money is going to be reinvested to create new and more
dynamic businesses that will help the innovations will help our society move
forward. When you just redistribute that money,
it there's no more additional innovation. It's just, it's just,
it's being consumed.
This whole idea that it's consumption that drives the economy is
fundamentally a myth.
It's mostly creativity and innovation that drives the economy.
So we need to keep that money in the hands of our most creative people,
which are entrepreneurs and creative business people. And for some reason,
I probably, I think because of envy, it seems so unfair. Again,
we in a win lose model.
If Jeff Bezos has $150 billion,
then that's unfair in some sort of cosmic way. That's unfair.
And they believe that some or another others have less.
So there's like this fixed pie and Jeff took a big piece of it or, or, or,
or Elon Musk is taken a big piece of it, but it's not a fixed pie.
That's the wrong metaphor. Innovation ism is continually growing the pie.
And in fact,
humanity is demonstrably better off because of the capitalist because of the
innovation.
Let me play devil's advocate. Cause this is the way they look at it.
They would say, well, when you get to that sort of a position like a Jeff Bezos,
we have $150 billion.
You can exert your influence on people in a way that's detrimental to
society. You've achieved too high of a position.
You have too much power and you will probably lose,
use that power to loosen regulations,
to bribe politicians or influence politicians and to get
laws passed that are better for your business and stifle competition.
I think that's a powerful argument. And if, and when it happens,
you have to push back against, you have to resist it.
I think most business people are not doing that.
I think I don't see that Jeff's trying to pass or I,
or I don't see Mo I don't see Jeff trying to pass.
No, I don't think he is. He's on. I'm not saying he is. If he was boy,
would they come after him? Yeah. Cause he's bawling so hard. They'd be like.
He is doesn't have enough.
But I know that before when whole foods was,
we were a public company for 25 years and we had the government go after us a
few times, uh, for, uh, they tried to stop our,
we tried to make an acquisition of a,
of a company called wild oats back in 2007, we actually made the acquisition,
but the FTC tried to stop it.
We ended up going into court with them and we actually won in court and very
interesting. The FTC has their own court and they,
after we won in the federal courts, they said, well,
now we want to take you into the, our court.
Oh, terrific. They have their own court. They had their own court.
Don't you wish you had your own court take you to whole foods. Court.
I'll take you to the whole town court. Right. But you know, the people's court,
you don't win in the FTC court. You don't win in that court.
So how many people have won in that court?
I think when I've looked at it at that time, this back in 2007,
I think 46 of the 48 previous cases. This is from memory. So I could be wrong,
had lost. They should go to court. Someone should take them to,
but here's the thing I asked our attorney, so, okay.
We're going to lose in this court, in their court, then what happens?
This isn't well, then you appeal that back to the federal courts.
And then after that, if they want to, they would go to the Supreme court.
If they'll take it. I said,
how much is it going to cost me to just fight him in their own courts?
They said, it's going to cost you $30 million legal fees.
Not to mention a lot of executive time. And it's like, man,
30 million and we're gonna know we're gonna lose.
And then we're gonna have to spend another $30 million to go to the appeals of
beyond that. The lawyers love it. By the way,
of course they want you to do it like divorce lawyers. Yes, exactly.
Let's love it. It's how people fight. Not talk. Don't talk,
don't try to work this out because he's going to try to you,
don't try to steal your money. He's going to try to steal that money from me.
A piece of. Look at him, look at him. Um, so again, so what did you do?
You wind up settling. We ended up, yes. We ended up,
they let the merger go through and we agree to sell off a bunch of stores.
And that was, that was the best we could do.
How many stores you have to sell off? Uh, we,
we put up about 30 for sale and we,
we only about about, I dunno, I think five or six, we sold about five or six.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st to December 1st,
they're going to be available everywhere,
but after December 1st they will only be available on Spotify,
but they will be free. That includes the video. The video will also be there.
It'll also be free. That's all we're asking. Just go download Spotify much.
Okay.